les qure saisons avec un très joli décor
préparé par Jean-Paul carer et nos amis
décorateurs c'est un vrai feu hein c'est
[Musique]
interdit le jour de ma 16
printemps tandis qu'au loin Batelle la
fê nous volions sur nos
bicyclètes et nous rions sa belle
d le jour de mes 16
[Musique]
printemps je n'étais Guer
entreprenant mais prenis l'alure
distraite quand je fumais les cigaret
des
Venard qui avait 20 ans l'air Pharo je
faisait semblant de cacher des pensées
secrètes quand je taaquinais
Marinette le jour de mai 16
[Musique]
printemps le jour de mes 35
été ma fille souffla mé
Chand ma mère souriait au près d'elle ma
femme éclatait de beauté le jour de mes
été je voyais au fond de leurs yeux tant
d'amour et de joie tranquille que les
tumultes de la ville me
versaient comme un champ heureux j'avais
les temples
argentés il se dessinait quelqu
r mais le ciel était tout limpide le
jour de mai 35
[Musique]
été le jour de Maes 60
automne je me
diraiis mon vieux
gamin tu as fait les tr/arts du
chemin c'est l'heure des souvenirs qui
sonent le jour de mes so
automne le poid de deux fois 30 années
ne rendrat- c'est génè aurais-je l'art
d'être grand-père saurais-je parler au
passé je t'enfuis et nous F personne
mais fin printemps c'était
hier le
temps reflit comme une
mer le jour de mer
autom
j'essaierai
d'oublier
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'hiver jolie hein